ん
くそ大丈夫かいいがます もうすいません帰りますかはいやりたくないといけないん
ブーブー言っていた方がいいかもん いやっこさんもっふーれさっきましたん
ん
うんありがとうさあお名前言ってたことしようやっぱりねん
we have we have lunch together and then i want to take it to some place
あまりも日にちがないんでも今年だけはの tt でもいいなんじゃなくても
本当に来られていかっきゃですまたもう2年2年以上カレーザー来てなくて
ああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ 次も次もも行っているあの気が入りってね
間でいくねとねっ ドリキャーここにないんだもんだからうん
うん 今度また同じ場所たぶん
おっ 受け付けたらいい
ん 私はの実物があるんだけどそうですよねでもこれを
ん 今度は一つの間にあるんですけどねーっ
ん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん
ん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん スゴイん
今年が馬の年です これさ、物置に付いてないから最後、よかった これ全部に付きました
守り神的な感じのありがたい 玄関にあると魔除けになるっていう
ヨーロッパーがあるとね、皆さんこういうのを付けて
うちとちもその話を聞いて、すべての建物にありがたくいただいて、この機能です
ありがとうございます
特別な…
これ持ってく?
馬やられてる人はね、自分の馬の手で付くとね